so we're having a hard time making
payroll uh the same night I came home
Jen had a miscarriage I'm outside by
myself it's 1 30 in the morning uh I
don't have any more money left I don't
know how I'm going to make payroll Boom
the next week AIG sends a hundred
thousand dollar bonus check we were able
to make the payroll and then obviously
from there everything changes but this
is not a uh you know a one-off story
this is very common with everybody that
eventually wins at the highest level
you're going to have stories where you
are so close to losing everything how
you handle during those moments dictates
how much more pressure you can handle
later on